[Music]
good evening everyone and welcome to the
69th annual CMU alumni awards tonight we
honor Carnegie Mellon alumni and faculty
who are making contributions to their
industries their communities this
university and the world from the moment
a student steps onto campus their CMU
journey begins and tonight marks a
special night in that journey for our
honorees and for all alumni as a
reminder that our relationship with
Carnegie Mellon lasts a lifetime
our alumni never failed to impress me
with their professional and personal
accomplishments coming back to this
campus more than a decade ago becoming
very involved in the Alumni group has
been very special in my life and I have
seen such wonderful changes and I'm so
proud of the University and all that it
does and I feel blessed to be with
friends and colleagues each and every
day of my life and I really look forward
to staying engaged at the school and
being part of counting Mellon community
for years to come thank you for
acknowledging my partnership with CMU
with this very special honor tonight I
stress partnership because I actively
collaborate with the CMU community to
build a diverse and inclusive talent
pipeline and to increase the meaningful
representation of all underrepresented
groups in technology you know during the
30-plus years since my graduation I've
been involved in so many different
things the management gained the alumni
board it's truly an honor to be part of
the group here tonight as well as all
the different people that we saw in the
slideshow earlier and I thank you for
that the opportunity to be here tonight
I am so proud to say this is a great day
to be at our team life is as big or as
small as we choose to me
tonight's award winners have chosen to
live a large life the work ethic of CMU
and the hunger for knowledge keeps us
ahead of the curve with a platform to
influence and shape our industries our
society and our communities whenever I
had achieved whatever I have been able
to attain I recognized that Carnegie
Mellon was a core part of what opened my
eyes to the world I would have never
imagined and for that I'm always great
thank you all so much I think that I may
be the only honoree tonight who can say
it is good to be on this stage again I
believe that we are all stars and many
of the honorees tonight our stars and
their own profession I step foot into
Carnegie Mellon and it took me a little
while but I realized that the school was
filled with people that had great ideas
and was filled with people that were
ambitious in different ways and we're
creative and thoughtful when I was doing
my eighth grade science project my
mother who was a high school librarian
brought home a book on particle
accelerators and I thought it was the
most interesting thing throughout the
evening we have learned of individuals
who advanced their communities
strengthened dis University shape our
culture and serve as captains of
enterprise just as CMU has shaped so
much of Todd's life and career his
long-standing service to Carnegie Mellon
has quietly and surely helped to shape
this university Todd Johnson exemplifies
what it means to be a Carnegie Mellon
graduate
he's a vanguard of his industry and a
true inspiration to our community in my
experience my career came from the
professor's like alkene and my
experiences at the University and it's
been beyond my wildest dreams of what's
possible which is a dream that everyone
should have I want to offer my sincere
congratulations to the eleven honorees
this evening you bring pride to your
alma mater and serve as inspiring role
models for our graduates
once again please join me in a round of
applause for this year's award
recipients
you
[Applause]